You just added a powerful user to your
server that authenticates using a user
name and password.
Hopefully, you chose a strong password
since attackers will soon start running
bots against your server attempting to
guess any valid usernames and passwords.
This is going to cause all sorts
of issues for your server.
Your logs are going to be filled
with invalid login attempts, and
if one of these hackers
manages to gain access,
well that's about the worst
thing we could possibly imagine.
There's another way to perform user
authentication that's much more secure.
It doesn't rely on passwords, which
we're pretty horrible at making secure,
since we have to make them
simple enough to memorize.
Instead, this form of authentication,
called key based authentication,
relies on physical files
located on the server and
your personal machine,
the one you're logging in from.
Before we get into key
based authentication,
let's demonstrate how public
key encryption generally works.